she married my best friend I was a
groomsman in the wedding like I'm so and
I said hey hopefully you know the next
one works out for you and here's the
message she goes baby I'm the modern day
Elizabeth Taylor if you're not familiar
with Elizabeth Taylor do you know how
many times Elizabeth Taylor was married
take the over out there Elizabeth Taylor
was married eight times so I believe
that Kim is now on her fourth marriage I
want to say Drake don't end up number
five homie I think Kanye when they got
divorced
even though she's a billionaire and he
was a billionaire he still has to pay
her not one not two two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars a month in
spousal support and child support
whatever it's labeled under
so that's almost three million dollars a
year
in spousal support child support she's a
billionaire the men out there you will
be taken to the cleaners
even if your woman has money